they said my first time hi ah I went
through my name is flora Nabila I from
Naples Italy
this is my niece she don't speak English
I never ever present pasta to make good
pasta make the measurement of right you
know the flour the semolina and I come
right I know I do right when I make
pasta segreto el amor a Marat lamb or a
No
[Music]
for us the past the neck aprender is a
name no pasta it looks ugly to speaking
with right the vemma cetera is it no
cook it's very hard I'm sorry
you know my kind of pasta I make this
salad it looked like dilip like lasagna
but to me is no lasagna
[Music]
[Applause]
No hey I like ragout with poor lasagna
the pasta al dente now not magic and the
South's I ever know with this kind place
it's like the acid salsa so the total
utility pistol Monocacy i'm alessandra
you know the shamrock is key for my new
lasagna I'm sorry maybe American people
are like good it look like the ball you
need to sell your lobster ravioli even
so many caliber of Torino Cobra d'Italia
[Applause]
[Music]
with each PR number so numbers enjoy
yell at somebody one serve this to me
I tell I'm sorry I can eat pasta a man
died I died
the record is not smooth it's very like
tests like karate
see general better school something's on
my yeah my my get soggy
I guess or you know it's little pasta
they said were they born amantha no I I
don't eat meat no man chuckling I'm
gonna tell em no way no way no way no we
don't have Angela do i Sol de Maintenon
distich overlooks a reward at the court
not request a call we are crystal super
gay yeah no my comment my community I'm
Angela Quinn America PlayStation Oh
spaghetti twisted Colossus vertical
shear force at Cigna Maravich Oh Casey
quest oi
I like garlic I cook with garlic or my
country boy for sale única cosa nakida 1
décimo say to take one leg across a pico
mystic be late but can the rest Ramat
Eshkol toes can also display a dear Lord
Varys Posada Minami Kavita burrow
suppose a man Johnny and niente
ah I went through
[Music]